bobo wants to talk about something
you're going to hobo you're going to
massage parlors no no no no no i went
for a massage that's what i was telling
them you know many times but i'm going
to tell you anybody says you don't get
aroused they're full of [ __ ] i mean
you're in the dark room the ambiance is
there the music is mellow what was that
word you used that started with an a
avion um what do you say it again yeah
the whole arbiance of it it's the way
it's all dark in there it's very say the
word again slowly ambiance
yeah obvious how you spell that
let me see obvious a b a
i a n c e i think ambiance obviously
okay i i just never i've never heard it
said like that uh thank you for sharing
yeah you're saying
you're saying the whole ambiance was uh
nice in the massage room yeah it's very
sensual it's it's erotic you know it's
dark you hit a music faintly playing and
she has all these oils and it smells
nice in there
oh yeah that that gets anybody uh
excited how do you say the word massage
massage massage
i noticed that like sal and guys with
low iqs
all say massage yeah they do the hard
geese they drag out that ge sound
you hear regular people talk and say
massage right and you say
besides say it again massage yeah there
you go what do you say to the masseuse
when you got that big bone sticking up
straight up
i'm just saying it's always in your mind
that you have that oh my god what if you
know what i mean it just goes to all
guys minds when they go in no
all right bubba i got to go
thank you for describing the ambiance
yeah you're welcome